hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown after getting
blocked by a federal appeals court the
occupational safety and health
administration is suspending its
enforcement of the biden
administration's covit 19 vaccine
mandate which would require businesses
with over 100 employees to get fully
vaccinated or tested weekly kansas
senator roger marshall one of a number
of republicans pushing back against the
mandate joins the rundown to discuss and
weigh in on the democrats economic
agenda
aaa predicts 53.4 million people will be
on trains planes or highway lanes this
thanksgiving travel expert mark murphy
shares his thoughts on what holiday
travelers can expect the potential for
delays and whether the industry has
rebounded from the pandemic plus
commentary by fox news contributor joe
koncha the fox news rundown is a daily
news podcast where we take a deeper look
at the stories important to you you
could subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm charles payne i'm martha mccallum
i'm greg jarrett and this is the fox
news rundown
friday november 19 2021 i'm mike
emmanuel americans are demanding answers
about the origins of covet 19 and a
group of bipartisan senators plan to
deliver with an independent commission
to dig into the circumstances
of the pandemics outbreak still to this
day there's more questions than answered
just to help prevent future pandemics
like this as well as how to respond when
when bad infections do break out we have
to figure out these answers we speak
with medical doctor and kansas senator
roger marshall and lisa brady everything
is not back to normal but it may feel a
lot like old times for holiday travelers
thanksgiving travel week it's going to
be huge in terms of travel so be
prepared for long lines be prepared for
a lot of weights be prepared potentially
for lots of cancellations and have a
backup plan
and i'm joe koncha i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
in the aftermath of the september 11th
attacks an independent bipartisan
commission was created by congress to
prepare a full and complete account of
all the facts surrounding the 2001
terrorist attacks
now there's a bipartisan push to create
that same type of commission to look
into the origin of covet 19.
that effort is being led by republican
senators roger marshall and joni ernst
and democratic senators dianne feinstein
and kirsten gillibrand with the origin
of the virus coming from china a deep
dive into covid could be awkward for
president biden on the foreign policy
front since it's widely believed china
misled the world on kovid china's trying
very hard to
project itself as a responsible
and a very very forthcoming nation
that they are trying very hard to talk
about how they're taking and helping the
world in terms of covenanting
is china really actually trying to get
to the bottom of this for now the
president's doing a diplomatic dance
with beijing it's just inconceivable
that we've not done a real basic dive
into what happened with covet where did
it come from as well as our response
senator roger marshall md represents the
state of kansas i'm very grateful for
senator feinstein senator jill labrand
from the democrat side of the aisle and
of course joni ernst from my side
working together to get this
accomplished i i just think it's so
important that we understand why where
did this where did this come from you
know if a plane wrecks we go to all
types of links to find out why that
plane crashed right and in this case a
plane crashed with millions of people on
it we don't know where it came from and
we haven't even begun to look what our
response would be so i think you know i
consider gillibrand's case uh gosh new
york was on the tip of the spear in so
many cases when it when it came to covet
i think that they both have some
emotional
you know situations there why this is
important to them and i appreciate them
stepping forward
showing the leadership to say look we've
got to investigate this in addition to
representing the great state of kansas
you are also a medical doctor so you
bring a medical background to this
investigation yeah exactly uh you know
we volunteered very early on you go back
to march of 2020 we were working in
icu's ers
in clinics in urban america as well
i really been following this story since
january of 2020 when i first saw some
news reports come out and this just
didn't make sense what i was reading in
my first conversation with the cdc in
january of 2020 didn't go well i thought
that they were hiding some information
from us i just found the alarm then and
still to this day there's more questions
than answered just to help prevent
future pandemics like this as well as
how to respond when when bad infections
do break out we have to figure out these
answers and those of us still walking
around wearing masks a year and a half
into this crisis even though we're
vaccinated obviously there are concerns
about the possibility that what if
there's another pandemic over the
horizon and making sure the united
states is better prepared right yeah
exactly mike and i'm so proud of the
work that we're starting to get done on
the health committee to understand what
we were we were supposedly set up for a
for a pandemic like this but obviously
we had some failures but we also started
doing things better the fda found that
it can move a little bit more quickly
the nih found that it could move a
little more quickly as well but we
absolutely were caught uh with our pants
a little bit short of when it came to
ppe
and and certainly we've just got a lot
of work to get ready uh for the next
pandemic and certainly just even
understanding the science
you obviously know traveling the halls
of congress how polarized things are
right now how do you avoid the blame
game finger pointing
which is really so common today in
washington
well i think on this particular issue
we keep focusing on number one is why
why we need to understand the origin of
covid
look so many people lost a loved one who
died a very lonely death those people
need closure um
i i think if if this virus came from
nature we need to start building
vaccines so i think we need to be
focused on on not necessarily the
politics of it but make this totally
apolitical and that's why we're trying
to set this up that five uh the
democrats will get to pick five people
for this commission the republicans
would get to pick five and hopefully
those would all be a political people uh
so i think we stay focused on the
science stay focused on uh the whys of
how this happened
let's talk about another issue you're
working on with some of your republican
colleagues uh senator kevin kramer from
north dakota rick scott from florida
roger wicker from mississippi along with
the first liberty institute general
counsel mike berry in terms of navy
seals fighting the vaccine mandate what
are your concerns sir well the the white
house uh is obviously wants to separate
all of our soldiers from from the
service if they refuse the vaccine and
probably goodness i really think there's
still 20 percent of folks out there have
not are not going to get the vaccine
and the white house has publicly said
they want those soldiers to have a
dishonorable discharge and i think it's
important your your listeners understand
what a red check mark a dishonorable
discharge is my dad was chief of police
for 25 years and in my hometown of el
dorado and i remember him saying he
would never hire a service person with a
dishonorable discharge
beyond that they of course would lose
their va benefits education benefits
access to the hospital in some states
they would lose voting rights
access to health care as well so we turn
these heroes into zeros
and if i could just go on i just want to
bring this really home
if you get this heart inflammation your
career as a navy seal you're done if
you're an air force pilot you're done
they'll probably never let you fly again
so would you be willing to put your
career on the line for this vaccine
which has known side effects and and
just to make sure i communicate with
your listeners properly look i'm
encouraged people to consider the
vaccine my parents have had the vaccine
they've had the boost or i've had the
vaccine but it's two different groups of
people and that's why you can't take a
sledgehammer to every problem like the
white house is trying to do with these
vaccine mandates and i've heard it's not
just military folks that there's lots of
people who are serving on the front
lines at the united states southern
border who are concerned about the
vaccine mandate and so this may go well
beyond the military as well
yeah there's there's not an industry in
this country that will not be impacted i
think if you dive into any industry uh
that you're gonna find 20 30 percent of
the people are not vaccinated nor do
they want to be vaccinated and they've
taken a deep dive they understand the
pros and cons of it and they made that
decision that's why a federal mandate
any type of federal mandates is not
going to work but especially one where
we're gonna take up you know a
relatively new medication and put it in
your body so it'll impact everybody uh
it's gonna exacerbate our labor
shortages clog up the supply chains even
worse when i say vaccine mandate you
should automatically think inflation
that's what's going to occur from this
is more inflation as they try to
implement this four million people quit
their jobs last month in america four
million people quit a job and i think
one of the main reasons is this vaccine
mandate
you made reference to inflation i went
to the gas station late last night
filled up could not believe the numbers
i was seeing
i think any folks who have been to the
grocery store recently are seeing some
eye-popping numbers of
everyday products they love and they use
that are certainly a lot more expensive
these days what are your concerns about
inflation and how is it affecting your
folks back home well in inflation and
vaccine mandates are the number one and
two issues i'm hearing the most about
and with the most volume back home but
but you're right gasoline prices are up
60 groceries
gosh they're saying it's 10 or 15 but
when i go it feels like it's 20
everything that i've wanted to buy
whether it was a new battery for my
truck uh or new tires everything seems
like it's up twenty percent it cost over
a hundred dollar bill to fill up my
dodge ram truck now uh this is not
something you can just say okay let's
let's stop the inflation i've lived
through the 80s
this is going to be a problem for a year
or two and forever if we don't stop
these horrible policies coming out of
the white house
speaking of those policies your
democratic colleagues are still looking
to pass this 2 trillion or so
dollar social spending package
democrats are still trying to get that
across the finish line
is senator joe manchin the key player in
all this or are you convinced that there
are some other moderate democrats
uh in the senate who have real
reservations when you consider inflation
and what it may do to our economy well i
think the people up front and center are
joe manchin and kirsten cinema kirsten
has really been fighting back all these
tax raises and we appreciate her and all
of her work she actually gets it she
understands business she understands the
tax policies and how they would
negatively impact america as well
joe seems to be standing tall remember
who joe represents
those folks in west virginia are
conservative hard work working people
just like folks from kansas or in many
many states so i think joe is doing
everything he can to fight for those
folks back home and i just encourage
them to keep reaching out to them and
say stand tall we appreciate you
standing tall so by if they they want to
borrow more money it's going to lead to
more inflation
which is taxes people on the on the
fringe ends even more than other people
my senior citizens on fixed incomes
young hard working families those are
the ones really pulling the sting of
inflation
are you surprised by how this is all
played out you had joe biden running as
a moderate uh someone who had been in
government for his adult life basically
uh with a 50 50 senate and a single
digit majority in the house of
representatives wouldn't this have been
a golden opportunity to kind of lock
arms between the two parties and tackle
some of the major problems affecting the
country and not go
way off the left reservation in terms of
this social spending package
well i guess i wasn't totally surprised
when president obama was in office i was
a hard-working physician i still had i
think two kids in high school and two in
college and someone said don't watch
what he says watch what he does
and as i saw this biden team assembling
it was basically the
obama retreads and the most liberal of
the of that group right
so i was very concerned that what he
said what he was going to do i wouldn't
be the same and and here we are later
like you said a 50-50 senate
but they borrowed 4 trillion dollars
already on top of the annual budget
right but yet we don't have the ndaa
done the national defense authorization
act done so they're trying to spend
money which isn't easy you think it'd be
hard it'd be easy but it's hard to spend
six seven trillion dollars out of whack
so they've been so busy with that i
think they've taken their eye off the
ball some other basic common issues like
national security
for one thing
senator roger marshall medical doctor
senator from the great state of kansas
thank you so much for your time have a
wonderful day sir thanks mike glad to be
with you
[Music]
this is joe koncha with your fox news
commentary coming up
this could be the busiest holiday travel
season since before covet the
thanksgiving travel period officially
starts today we expect to see
substantial increase in passenger
volumes
which will be approaching
the pre-pandemic 2019
period
volume that we saw
from two years ago robert duffy is the
tsa's federal security director for new
york's laguardia airport he says
staffing will not be a concern we've
been hiring on an ongoing basis
since early summer
and will continue to do throw into early
2022.
we also have the opportunities overtime
but that doesn't mean there won't be
long lines as some americans take their
first trip in more than a year one adobe
analytics report in september suggested
summer air travel had been dampened by
kovid's delta variant but aaa is
predicting that for the thanksgiving
holiday alone more than 53 million
people will be on the move up 13 from
last year and while most will be on the
roads they expect an 80 percent increase
in air travel just a few weeks after the
u.s reopened to many international
travelers though there are vaccine and
cobia testing rules to follow i think
with the restrictions you still have a
major
impediment for travel mark murphy is a
travel analyst and author and i think
you still have people that when you come
to a country like the united states when
you go state to state city to city
you've got rules of engagement that
differ depending on where you're at so
there's not one uniform countrywide
policy so we have seen a nice uptick
but as you've probably also noticed
other than
the
excitement and announcement and people
kind of rejoining family members they
haven't seen in a couple years there
hasn't been much more about it and i
think that's pretty indicative of where
the travel industry is at today it's
still suffering greatly
but there are some bright spots
i wanted to drill down with you a little
bit on the airline industry because i've
read multiple times that business travel
is lagging and that's a crucial part
especially for the airline industry of
their bottom line but i guess by
extension for hotels and things like
that
is business travel ever going to be back
to the volume that it had before so
business travel is interesting because
there's technology now that allows you
to do things
that you would normally get on a plane
and go
to meet with somebody face to face to do
so do i think it's changed for good the
answer is yes i think it has changed for
good i think that one of the challenges
you're going to have with business
travel is all the pieces it touches down
line so
sure it's the airplanes and that's where
they focus their marketing efforts
because those are their high yield
customers somebody who's a business
traveler finds out on friday night that
they have to fly out sunday to san
francisco last minute booking that
leisure ticket if you would becomes a
two thousand dollar round trip whereas
the guy who bought it four weeks ago is
paying 450. so that's where a lot of the
profits made that doesn't exist to any
anywhere close to the pre-pandemic level
it is coming back i think one of the
things that you'll see
that's indicative of that are
conferences
incentive trips and things of that
nature are coming back
i think the guy getting on a plane to go
make a bunch of sales calls
has definitely been pulled back i don't
think that'll return to what it was but
the industry will adapt and on routes
where
the
uh flights are not filling up in the
front of the plane they've got to have a
different strategy and it's going to be
a price driven strategy and it's going
to be a packaging strategy with
packaging leisure hotels with airline
tickets with car rentals etc
that's going to be the approach and
they're going to have to adapt or
they're going to have to pull back on
those uh segments that they fly you know
instead of flying six times to london
from laguardia from jfk and they might
fly three times a day if you're american
airlines for instance
we have heard in addition to staffing
shortages and
the wave of cancellations recently by
southwest and american um you know all
the stories of confrontations on
airplanes over mask mandates
do you think that's holding a
substantial number of people back from
traveling just not wanting to deal with
any of it
when you find out that somebody not only
got their flight cancelled
30 minutes before it was set to take off
that they couldn't get out of that city
for three days as a result these people
have families kids school work and they
can't they can't get where they're
supposed to be getting and
in the old days if you had a major
snowstorm it would take between 24 and
72 hours to basically work out that
domino effect in some cases you have to
travel to a different airport at your
cost book a separate ticket at your cost
you might get a refund back but the
problem is that one-way ticket you're
buying at that secondary airport on a
different airline is now at maximum cost
because they do this thing called yield
management and you're paying through the
nose so yeah it gets very expensive and
i think that's a big turn off for
travelers and the headache associated
with it i think that's why you're seeing
aaa is saying we're gonna have record
numbers i think we have more people on
the road this year than we've had since
2005 and
you know air travel is going to be
back to pre-pandemic levels this coming
weekend uh week i should say uh
thanksgiving travel week it's going to
be huge in terms of travel so be
prepared for long lines be prepared for
a lot of weights be prepared potentially
for lots of cancellations and have a
backup plan that includes driving or
flying on a different carrier and check
with the contract of carriage on the
carrier because make sure that if you
end up getting out okay you can cancel
that backup flight with no penalties and
get a full refund
but again you most of the time you pay a
high premium to have that flexibility
yeah you just answered some of my next
question about you know traveling in
general being more stressful than ever
right now and especially for a family
who maybe has a flight booked for the
holidays
getting ready to go to the airport
anything else you can offer about you
know being mentally prepared to wear a
mask getting there early things like
that
wear a helmet
no kidding
so
what you want to do is if you are going
to go ahead and get away during the
holidays you want to have a backup
destination potentially
you want to have a backup plan to get
there i mean if you're flying to
an island you can't swim there so you're
kind of stuck flying there
you want to make sure that if you're
taking a cruise for instance
you that you are prepared
and know that if your flight gets
canceled because the crew doesn't show
up which just happened to a friend of
mine earlier this week on alaska
airlines not one that we've heard a lot
about and he got stranded for an extra
day in seattle
that's that's a fact that the cruise
line doesn't care about because the
cruise line is going to take off with
your money and an empty cabin whether
you're delayed or not they're they're
not holding the ship for you so if
you've got a family of four going on a
cruise and you're dropping five or six
thousand bucks for that cruise
then you better make sure that you fly
into a place like fort lauderdale or
whatever destination your cruise is
going out of two or three days in
advance
to be completely safe but we're so down
to the wire now most people have already
made those plans so i would recommend
that they look at
bookending that trip and figuring out do
they have the flexibility without taking
a financial hit to modify that
reservation
take the kids out of school if they're
in person these days if they're not it
doesn't matter you can do it remotely
and take a hotel
do a pre-departure
hotel stay and that way you're going to
be in a situation where even if you're
delayed the odds are you're going to
make it there ultimately i mean if
you're coming from new york
theoretically it's a 16-hour drive to
fort lauderdale maybe 18 hours and
it would stink but you could still get
there and catch the cruise if your
flight got canceled and you couldn't get
rebooked the next day you would still be
able to get there but it would become
the trip from hell and it's not a good
way to start a vacation
but it's really all about alternatives
and trying to to plan out alternatives
as early as you can for people who want
to book a trip and maybe it's not too
late they haven't booked it yet um
not necessarily for the holidays but
even into early next year
any advice for saving money is there a
better time to book regardless of how
you're traveling and i ask this partly
because
you know fuel costs have gone up i'm
imagining that prices for virtually
every kind of travel are reflecting that
the best time to travel
is when you're not
right in the middle that holiday crunch
right don't travel if you can avoid it
around thanksgiving don't travel over
the christmas break if you can avoid it
travel between the thanksgiving break
and before christmas gets into full
swing by like december 18th 19th
complete your travels you will see that
a cruise departure
is a fraction of the cost
in those
those weeks in between versus
thanksgiving week and boy christmas it
spikes through the roof then after the
uh new year's break look at all of the
options over the next like from around
january 4th or 5th out to january 15th
18th whenever martin luther king
holiday is this year i don't know the
exact date it's always on a monday uh
and people take three day weekends
sometimes they'll go away
and then you've got the next one which
is president's day so you'll find that
that january the first few weeks of
january tend to be great values at
resorts because they clear out in places
like mexico those all-inclusives and
that's the other thing all-inclusive
resorts are a fantastic option and all
of these the best way to book all of
these is always with a travel
professional i always stress that i know
a lot of travel agents i had a business
that addressed them from a media
standpoint gave them information but as
well as consumers and when you find a
good one they know what the rules of the
road are they know what the covid
policies are they make sure you have
everything buttoned up you don't show up
and realize i didn't get the test and i
needed a negative test or whatever it
happens to be and they're there when
things go awry so instead of you
standing in line with 300 other people
trying to rebook your trip they're
working for you because you have their
cell phone you're like hey mary
yeah and she and mary goes yeah i i just
got a notice your your plane got
cancelled i'm working on a backup that's
a person in your court so in addition to
looking at those gaps where there's less
demand and there's tons of supply
always book with a travel agent and
people don't realize that booking with a
travel agent cost them nothing because
the travel supplier
pays for that as opposed to them having
to pay their own people to answer 100
questions from the family that's going
away for a one-week cruise or
all-inclusive vacation in cancun etc
mark murphy travel analyst and
best-selling author we thank you as
always for your time
appreciate it thanks for having me
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at
guybensonshow.com rate and review the
fox news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
dina martin loves to sing and entertain
and she comes by and honest her father
was the legendary dean martin
i caught up with dina recently and i
asked her to share a little good news
with me she told me one of the things
that has brought her a lot of positive
vibes is the social media exchange she
has with fans during her weekly facebook
live events she's been doing them for
more than 85 weeks in a row now and she
says putting good feelings out into the
world has really made a difference in
her own life it's quite remarkable to
sit here and and be able to sing and
someone is sending me a message saying
oh i love that song you know i'm in
ireland and
you know it's it's quite spectacular so
good news to me is that we've been able
to bring some light into all of these
people who have been shut in for all of
this time she has a give and take with
the audience in real time as they post
their comments song requests and jokes
and she says the scope of the whole
thing is sometimes hard to get your head
around dina says she works on new songs
for her fabulous fridays with friends it
is mind-blowing and it's a little scary
because you know it's a new song and
maybe i don't know it and i'll mess up
the words and i laugh just like my dad
used to do
you know you make a mistake just go on
you know smile about it and so the
people there you know and they're
sending me jokes you know and so i'm
telling their jokes and it's it's funny
because some they're just you know corny
which is fine and i'll mess them up and
they love that she's also been working
on the new documentary dean martin king
of cool which is out now you can join
dina every friday afternoon at four
o'clock eastern on facebook tanya j
powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
joe koncho
what's on your mind yep and watching
other cable news networks and late night
comedy shows on the broadcast networks
it's like a memo went out making it
mandatory to call 18 year old kyle
rittenhouse a racist i mean only in this
country can a white guy shoot three
other white guys and somehow race has
made the central issue in the coverage
maybe that's because the president of
the united states once called
rittenhouse a white supremacist which
set off the echo chamber you're seeing
now
some of the people making these charges
against written house are the same
geniuses who claimed winsome sears the
first black woman to win stateside in
virginia supports white supremacy which
makes total sense it's like the movie
dumb and dumber playing on a continuous
loop except that's fiction this is the
real deal the good news is if sagging
ratings are any indication the american
people are getting sick and tired of
playing the race card from the bottom of
the deck i'm joe koncha
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at fox news foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes